okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about square roots and radicals so this
is something that the makers of the act
obviously wanted us to understand
so let's talk about how to work with the
square roots and the radicals and then
we'll go through some
typical type examples that would be uh
on the test so the first example that we
want to talk about is just you know
recognizing that when you square
something versus when you square root
something those are just opposites and
inverses of one another okay so they
just undo or reverse one another out so
let's just talk about how to simplify
some of these square roots and then
we'll get into the more typical type
problems that might be asked on the act
so the square root of 32 you want to
know how to simplify that and the way
you do that is you divide out perfect
squares so you say like what's something
that
i can divide out a square root of 32
that's a perfect square well 16 times 2
see 16 is a perfect square the square
root of 16
is 4 so this is 4 square root of 2. now
square root of 2 i can't divide out any
perfect squares from there so i'm just
going to leave that as it is so 4 square
root of 2 would be the simplified
uh version of square root of 32. now
square root of 50 what can you divide
out of that well you can see there's a
25 times 2 square root of 25 is 5 and
the square root of 2 again we can't
simplify that one
okay so now the this one here is a
little bit more challenging because
we've got some variables involved
but what you want to do here when you
multiply is you want to multiply the
quantities on the outside of the square
roots together and the quantities on the
inside of the square roots together and
then simplify from there so 4 times 8 is
32
the square root of let's see 12
okay x squared times x is x cubed y
times y cubed is y to the fourth okay
now what we want to do is we want to
simplify this radical here square root
of 12 you can simplify that into
square root of 4 times square root of 3
okay and then x cubed you can break that
down into x squared times x and then y
to the fourth that's already
a perfect
square so let's see square root of 4 is
2 so 2 times 32 that gives us 64.
square root of x squared that gives us
just x okay square root of y to the
fourth that's just going to be y squared
because y squared times y squared gives
you back y to the fourth
square root of x is not a perfect square
and square root of three is not a
perfect square so that stays underneath
the radical
and that's it you've got it right there
okay let's look at some typical
typical examples
if 2x squared minus 9 equals 41 then
what does x squared plus 7 equal so
pause the video see if you can do this
one on your own and then we'll go
through it
okay so what you want to do here there's
a couple different ways to do this
problem but i think the most common way
that students would do this is just go
ahead and solve for x then we can put x
back in here and simplify so what we're
going to do is we're going to add 9 to
both sides so that gives you 2x squared
equals 50.
okay then we're going to work from the
outside in towards that x by doing the
opposites we're going to divide both
sides by 2
okay so that's x squared equals 25 and
then instead of squaring we're going to
do the inverse we're going to take the
square root of both sides so x equals
plus or minus 5. okay when you take the
square root of both sides of the
equation get two answers positive or
negative because a negative squared is a
positive and a positive squared is a
positive
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take that plus or minus 5 and
put it back in here well whether it's
negative or positive when you square it
a negative times a negative is a
positive positive times a positive is a
positive so negative 5 or positive pi
squared that's going to give you 25
plus 7 equals
32. so the answer to this question is
going to be 32. okay now example number
two
see if you can do this one if the square
of a number is between
908
and 1447
which of the following could possibly be
the number and they give us a bunch of
choices here 18 29 33 39 okay or 41.
so see if you can do this one on your
own go ahead and pause the video and
we'll do it together
now the thing they want us to realize is
that the square of a number okay so
basically if you square the number
you're going to get
908
or if you square the number you can get
1 447 and somewhere in between okay
these two that's our number right so
what they're testing us on is you know
do we recognize that squaring and square
rooting are inverses of each other if we
go ahead and take the square root of
both sides let's see what we get okay
i'm going to go to the calculator and
just see what this comes out to so
square root of 908
is 30.1 approximately okay and the
square root of 1447
is about 38 okay
so we're somewhere in between 30 and 38
so which one would that be well it can't
be 18 or 29 33 is in between 39 is not
41 is not so it looks like the best
answer here is letter c
33. so again just understanding how to
work with radicals and simplifying as
well as you know understanding that
square roots and
squares are inverses of each other is
important for you to
understand for the a c t